ukraine's army says its armed forces are
pushing further into the northeast
kharkiv region as it makes significant
gains and a counter-offensive well since
early september their advance has been
fast the ukraine taking back in days
ground that it took the russians months
to control o'keefe's forces have entered
the key towns of izum and kupiansk both
located on rail lines advances have also
been made by ukraine in the south near
hassan but at a slower pace
president vladimir zolensky claims his
troops have recaptured more than 2 000
square kilometers so far ukrainian flags
are being raised in towns that have been
controlled by moscow's forces for months
the russian defense minister says its
troops are regrouping in order to
bolster efforts in the donetsk region
what's the latest you're hearing about
the advances and we understand that uh
you've been in a difficult situation
there in in terms of a blackout is that
right
yes actually
we are in a blackout at the moment
actually there is
uh power outages in five
regions in the northeast and the eastern
part of the country there are also
unconfirmed report that there are power
power outages
all the way to
odessa but as i said those were
unconfirmed reports now what we're
hearing from officials is that
the russians have had critical
infrastructure they're not telling us
what or where uh but certainly there is
uh different this city
is in pitch black we were actually on
the streets
when that happened and as we were
driving back uh to our location
everything was completely dark there was
not one light on it was quite an eerie
scene as we understand it this is
happening also in ukraine's fourth
largest city department
nepal petrovsk is happening for example
in crematorus in the donetsk uh region
so in eastern ukraine in the dombas and
it's happening also in the sumi region
uh cert we don't know at this stage how
long this will last officials in the
various regions have also been telling
people to unplug their devices electric
devices if they don't need them they
have been telling them also to stock up
on water they say that the repairs are
ongoing but people are are wondering how
long that would last
and
obviously it might be difficult from
from where you are but from where you
were
can you tell us anything more about this
counter-offensive
well the counter-offensive is ongoing as
you mentioned earlier
i mean the ukrainians have made this
formidable advance since the beginning
of the month taking a lot of people by
surprise here many
wondering how did that happen especially
that there was this sort of stalemate
over the summer there was this war of
attrition between the two sides neither
sides making gains neither signs losing
grounds and then all of a sudden things
turned when the ukrainians got
more weapons from their western allies
especially
laser-guided precision missiles and
mobile
sort of high-tech
artillery
units that gave them an edge and all of
a sudden they were able to
hit the russians behind their defensive
lines and then push through their
defensive lines now
a lot of people here would tell you how
come the russians are just
running away leaving a lot of military
hardware behind them
we've seen a lot of videos posted by the
soldiers on social media as they
continue their advances through the
towns and villages in the northeast of
the country uh show all that amount of
military hardware that was left behind
now what we don't know yet is what's
happening in itsum we know that the
ukrainian army has reached that town a
critical strategic town for the russian
it it was sort of referred to as the
stronghold of the russian army in this
part of the country we know that there
is video circulating on social media
showing the ukrainian flag above certain
government buildings there but we are
not hearing from the government whether
that city is in total totally under
their control or not when that happens
it will certainly
be a huge blow for uh the russians
simply because issue is is so strategic
because it sits on this hub of highways
and railroads uh and it's from there
really that the russians were supplying
their troops that are carrying on this
other on the other battleground in the
donbass region now the question many
have is what will happen next what will
the russians do uh people don't expect
that they would they just pulled out
having no plan the russians are saying
they're regrouping uh so certainly a lot
of questions up in the air
but if the ukrainians manage to hold
their ground this will certainly be
a turn in this war they have the
momentum at the moment now their
challenge is to keep that momentum
okay hoda stay safe thanks for that
update
well frank lederwidge is a senior
lecturer in military strategy and law at
the university of portsmouth he joins us
from oxford uh good to have you with us
so from your experience looking at these
strategies is this a significant
military recapturing as ukrainians are
saying
well kerry yes it is this is a strategic
victory for the ukrainians of a similar
significance about probably greater
significance actually
than their
defeat of the russians in kiev in march
it's strategic for a couple of reasons
first of all it demonstrates the highest
levels in the international community to
a perhaps unwavering international
community in a doubting community that
ukrainians can impose serious losses on
the russians
and as trudeau said there it is
it's a turning point in
handing or demonstrating ukrainian
initiative
but it's also a demonstration of their
acumen of their skills in combined arms
warfare bringing all the gear and kit
and training that they've had over the
last few months in fact years
all together now to to take back
an area of land far greater than the
russians have taken since since april
it's very significant and it
demonstrates you know also ukrainian
ukraine's capabilities in deception
in
it's an intelligence coup
and it's a remarkable
display of uh of russian ineptitude
particularly in the military
intelligence
uh uh military intelligence role the
russians are suggesting it's simply a
strategic withdrawal of some kind is
there any merit to that
the world that is appropriate here is
route
it's a headlong retreat
there is no question of the russians
conducting anytime soon any form of
counter-attack and the reason kerry for
that is that the their lines are so
thinly held
and that's because ukraine has been
telegraphing for a long time a major
offensive in the south which is let's
not forget going on and going
successfully for the ukrainians around
the important city of kerasong it's
quite far to the west as that's going
going on the russians redeployed some of
their very limited and depleted forces
over there leaving that eastern front
depleted so
the russians are in headlong retreat i
have no doubt at all that serious
questions are being asked in moscow and
in the various headquarters i've no
doubt at all that heads will run quite
soon the russians are in a real mess
strategically then how much does the
sighting of something like the zaparisia
nuclear power plant play in the minds of
of both sides
yeah that that's a good question and
also plays into what federer was talking
about there about the power cuts that
have been imposed perhaps rather
petulantly by the russian some russian
airstrikes and missiles flights today
the
the issue of zapariza and particularly
the nuclear power station is strategic
it uh it plays on ukrainian fears going
right back to chernobyl in the early 80s
and those fears are still there uh it it
unsettles the people and of course it it
there's an abiding sense of
of uh fear in that in that respect but
let's not forget that over the last week
the ukrainian people have had news of
nothing but victory uh that morale is
generally high and this kind of uh
activity of blackouts or
threats uh irresponsible threats to
nuclear power stations that isn't going
to derail that
frank lloyd witch we very much
appreciate your time thank you
thanks